القائد الجديد للعمليه العسكريه الروسيه
سيكون في مواجهه الجيش الاوكراني في حلته
الجديده والتي تختلف تماما عن الشكل الذي
كان عليه قبل نحو اي عند سن العمليه
العسكريه الفارق الكبير بين الامس واليوم
هو الاسلحه الغربيه التي باتت تتدفق من كل
حدب وصوب لتتحول الى الصداع في راس بوتن
والجيش الروسي لكن اوكرانيا تتوفر على
امتياز اخر الى جانب التدفق الاسلحه وهو
القدره على صيانتها صحيفه وسط جورنال سلطت
الضوء على ورص صيانه الاسلحه المنتشره في
بولندا والتي تعمل على اصلاح الاسلحه
الاوكرانيه التي تتعرض للتخريب خلال
المعارك ويعمل فيها مئات الفنيه نتابع
ايضا ولان خضوع الاسلحه الى عمليات صيانه
يعد امرا اساسيه في الحروب فان فريقا
كاملا من التقنيين يحرص على هذه العمليه
من بولندا
كما ان بعض هؤلاء التقنيين على توا ده اما
على الجنود الاوكرانيين من اجل اعطائهم
توجيهات تقنيه بخصوص طريقه استخدام بعض
الاسلحه او كيفيه صيانتها ان كان الامر
ممكنا
ويضافوا هذا الدور الى ادوار اخرى لعبتها
بولندا في الحرب وبخاصه نتحدث هنا عن
دورها في امداد اوكرانيا بالاسلحه حيث
كانت المنفذ الاساسيه للاسلحه الغربيه كما
نعلم كما ان المعسكر الغربي راهن على
بولندا للمساهمه في اصلاح وصيانه دبابات
بسبب بمعرفه بولندا الكبيره التقديميين
البولنديين طبعا بهذه الدبابه الالمانيه
اما روسيا فيبدو انها تفتقد الى حد ما الى
ورث صيانه الاسلحه وهو ما دفعها الى
الاستعجال في اطلاق عمليه انشاء مركزين
جديدين لاصلاح الاسلحه في منطقه
لتدارك الموقف فضلا عن اجراءات عديده
طعميه
كان للعمليه العسكريه الخاصه التي بداتها
روسيا في اوكرانيا منذ نحو عام تاثير كبير
على مجمع الصناعات العسكريه باكمله لروسيا
حيث قال الرئيس الروسي ضد ماركوت ان عمل
المجمع هو احد عوامل نصر روسيا في
العمليات العسكريه لذلك استجابه لاحتياجات
الجيش اتخذت السلطات المختصه اجراءات
عديده منها زياده وتيره ونطاق الانتاج حيث
تحولت بعض الشركات الى العمل على مدار
الساعه وزادت بشكل كبير من انتاج المركبات
المدرعه والذخائر وانظمه الصواريخ
المتعدده الاطلاق
وزادت حجم الانفاق على الصناعات الدفاعيه
في مشروع الميزانيه لعام 2023